one of the things that I think is
poleaxed CEOs is that they are
simultaneously looking through a
microscope at every nickel and every
penny of cost and they say I want a
single-minded focus on cost while at the
same time they are all recognizing that
this recession is so big and so deep and
so broad that it is changing industry
structures I mean look at automobiles
look at financial services look at
retail look at just about every industry
you know we're reshuffling the deck and
and you know re dealing the cards and
and rebidding about what suit is Trump I
mean they're so they're going to be
there's going to be structural change in
every industry so to go back to the
other metaphor that suggests
simultaneously have to be looking
through the microscope at your cost and
looking through the telescope at what
your future is going to be and that's
kind of a difficult you know thing for
anybody for anybody to do and and I
think something similar it is involved
in the sustainability issues obviously
the first question about the
sustainability of a company is am i
alive I mean is securing liquidity and
making sure that I have the resources to
get through what is going to be you know
several more months at least of a pretty
difficult of suppressed demand and and
and difficult time so the first thing is
that liquidity and survival question and
I think most people mostly dealt with
that I mean at to some extent now we're
sort of like survivors of an earthquake
you know the whole everything's falling
down the walls are gone we sort of
emerged from the rubble and say I'm
alive now what and then I think there
are sort of two streams of activity one
stream of activity is how do I get
operationally fit get and stay
operationally fit the second stream is
how do i get strategically strong so the
operational Fitness is not the same as
being lean and mean when I think about
operational fitness one of the ways that
that we like to think about it and I
like to think about it is what are the
capabilities I have that given the
markets I'm in and the way they're
changing what are the capabilities I
have that give me a right to win and
what I want to do is I want to invest in
those capabilities and extend those
capabilities
and I want to disinvest from everything
else in so far as I can obviously
there's some things I have to do just to
keep the lights on but insofar as these
things are not part of my right to win
let me the best from them and put my
energy in my right to win driving
capabilities
the first of those questions is what
will the effect of a carbon constrained
world be on my income statement on my
ability to grow on my revenue and so on
and so forth the second is in a carbon
constrained world what will the effect
beyond my balance sheet on the value of
my assets on my risk profile so on and
so forth the third is what opportunities
are presented to me by a carbon
constraint world that might not be there
otherwise the fourth is what are the
implications of this kind of an
environment on all the stakeholders with
whom I deal whether those are my
employees or my customers or the
regulators and all the stakeholders
around the around the company and the
fifth is what can I do or what can we do
as an organization to reduce our own
greenhouse admissions and become
ourselves a a low-carbon business